hello or glad you've joined us for this
live webinar
flow cytometry approach to probiotic
cell counting and analysis i'm julie
O'Rourke of leopards and I'll be
moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab routes the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by Beckman Coulter
life sciences Beckman Coulter life
sciences develops manufactures and
markets products that simplify automate
and innovate complex pharmaceutical
quality control testing more than two
hundred and seventy-five thousand
Beckman culture systems operate in both
Diagnostics and life sciences
Laboratories on seven continents for
over 75 years our products have been
making a difference in people's lives by
improving compliance and reducing cost
of ownership to learn more about Batman
culture life sciences please visit w-w-w
dot dot dot slow kated on the far left
of your screen labeled ask a question
and click on the send button questions
will be answered after the presentation
to enlarge the slide window click on the
arrows at the top right hand corner of
the presentation window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support tab found at the top right
of the presentation window or report
your problem by typing it into the
answer a question box located on the far
left of your screen
I now presented a speaker Darleen chundo
a quality control senior microbiologist
and by de quest
international Darlene earned a Bachelor
of Science and molecular biology from on
Clair State University and she has
amassed more than 10 years of diverse
experience in research and in the
pharmaceutical industry she has
contributed to the successful launch of
two oncology drugs by ramza and port
rasa a live cat lui pharmaceutical
Darlene's research interest focuses on
the study of lactobacillus and
Bifidobacterium species she
is dedicated to developing a method to
analyze and obtain cell counts of
pronunciation on viable and non-viable
bacterial cells for the manufacture of
probiotic supplements using the flow
cytometry approach Darlene Tendo will
now begin her presentation thank you
very much
and like say today we are going to be
talking about the flow psychometric
approach to kind of optimize the
traditional method which is play count
mostly used for all microbiologist when
it comes to determining the viability of
probiotic cells and the reason why we
decided to look into this new approach
it was with a purpose to kind of
optimize the timing because this is a
very benefit for the industry especially
when production of probiotic supplements
or older products are in high demand
for a large scale production and we see
that in many many ways will we go to the
market we see from supplements to facial
masks to drinks to so many so many
products out there that definitely
optimizing our coming up with a new
method that saves time to the
manufacturer is of a great benefit in
definitely the turnaround time would be
very profitable so let's talk about the
market growth due to the market growth
there is a lot of different products
that are being manufacture a large scale
therefore there is a high need for these
products to be available to the
consumers usually when we do the
viability determination for these
products or the raw materials we have to
plate these samples and then it takes
about three days so we're talking about
a little time-consuming method and that
doesn't allow the manufacturer or the
vendor to release the products on a
timely manner as they desire so just to
tell you a little bit about the
traditional method um it's the play
count and it usually requires multiple
die lock dilution of the product because
um usually the product comes in powder
form or freeze dry form and therefore
requires different dilutions some
products might require less dilution or
more dilutions the add-on the others
usually takes three days in in those
three days you are able to collect the
results and that will let you report the
counts so we are the products ready to
be manufacture at that point so with
this method what we do is we make the
dilutions and then we will play them in
mrs agar or then member goes out in
sharp hour and then we would incubate it
in these chambers star anaerobic it
contains an a gas pack that it would
like maintain the chamber oxygen free so
this organism either lactobacillus or
bifida bacteria will grow at its optimum
environment now when we incubate for two
to three days at 37 degrees and then
we'll be ready to collect those results
so the method consists on planning these
products in duplicates for each single
sample that we test we will have to
duplicate the sample so for each sample
two plates then at the end what you see
is all these colonies on single plates
then we would have to count each of
these colonies and report
in DFU program or colony forming units
per gram and as you can see these plates
are really really covered in colonies
and sometimes it's really really tricky
and it can be challenging as well to
count all these colonies and have to
report a result in a timely manner when
you have let's say 20 or 30 samples in
one day as you can see this is really
really time-consuming so usually the two
different type of a species that we deal
with in the manufacture of these
supplements are Bifidobacterium and
lactobacillus and just to leave give you
a little overview about these two
species they are really challenging at
times because what happens when we
incubate these samples if we have single
colonies on our single species on it on
the plate the lactobacillus usually can
be differentiated from the
Bifidobacterium and we do that by
eyesight for example lactobacillus
colonies will be a little bigger and
bifidobacteria will be a little smaller
so sometimes we will have to leave the
Bifidobacterium plates for an extra day
this way we can um see the colonies and
have a more accurate count and this is
one challenging because when we have a
blend let's say a raw material sample
that contains Bifidobacterium and
lactobacillus we would have to treat
these sample differently than our
average sample and because of that
reasons it's a little trickier to kind
of differentiate between the two of them
and also we will have to in some cases
duplicated in four plates where you can
kind of modify the incubation
process for each of them this way you
will obtain a more accurate result
so these plating method it's not that
accurate when it comes to determining
their metabolic activity and also
physical characteristics of these
different species so why do we look into
flow cytometry well
flow cytometry it's a lot more rapid
method compared to the traditional and
it has the benefit that provide us more
data than the regular plating which
allows us to see if how many live cells
are viable cells we have within a sample
and how many that or non-viable cells we
have and this is a great thing because
with the plate we don't know how many
dormant cells or we have a certain
number of non-viable cells because the
culture dependent just cannot provide us
with a number and another thing is that
is cost-effective we are able to run
samples and get the results the same day
and that allows us to be more productive
because we are able to release those raw
materials in a more timely manner and
then manufacturing can go ahead and
produce all these products that need to
be released to the market um so it is
time efficient it saves us three days
compared to the traditional method and
also the beauty of this instrument is
that not only we are able to do single
sample or we using the tube loader but
we also have the plate loader which has
a 96-well plate and you can run as many
samples as you want it's it's great it's
easy to use you have as many samples as
you want you load your SEM
your stain samples and it has a feature
for auto record and you can basically
load your samples and walk away and the
instrument will do everything for you so
that's a great benefit this is just um a
little review of comparison compared to
the play count versus the young flow
cytometry method and this shows you in
detail kind of like where we start when
we receive the sample in the quality
control department and then the multiple
dilutions we have to do in order for us
to play verses the serial dilutions for
flow cytometry which are less and in the
play count sometimes we have to dilute
the sample up to ten full dilutions up
to ten to the tenth with flow cytometry
I usually do ten to the fifth for raw
materials and if we are analyzing any
other type of form like solid dose we
would do ten to the fourth which I found
very very optimal for collecting this
data and it gives you beautiful graphs
and very minimal electronic noise so
compared to the traditional method you
can see from the time we collect the
samples and we make the dilution and
then we stain ourselves and we incubate
them it only takes two hours and and
that is like a very large timing two
hours and it could be in those two hours
could be 10 to 20 samples depending on
the prep time and depending on on the
technician how quick we can get those
samples ready for the flow and the big
question is why did we pick side effects
well Saito Flags
it was um it was some instrument that we
thought if we could be the best thing or
the best option for us number one it was
because it's super modern automated
doesn't take much room and we literally
have it in Anna benchtop like in this
small table on underline
and it's it's a great instrument it's it
doesn't require too much space and the
beauty and the main thing of this
instrument is that it was able to
deliver to us what we were looking for
and what we're looking for is flow
cytometry that is able to read or detect
cells stars most 0.5 microns which are
like the size of the cells that we are
dealing with flows that this decimal
cytometry is able to detect cells as
small as 200 nanometers which is really
really sensitive and high-tech and we
really fell in love with it and we were
ready to give this instrument a try and
we were not disappointed at all the
results that we obtained with this
instrument were in accordance to the
results that we had with the cleaning
method and that's when we really agreed
that this was the right instrument for
us and that we were in the right track
just to give you a little overview about
the model that we are using we have the
Saito flex flows I turn blue red and
violet series all that means that it has
three different colors the red laser the
blue laser and violet and basically from
the blue laser we give five channels
from 488 nanometer laser and we get
three channels from the 638 nanometer
laser and five channels from the 405
violet laser and basically we can get up
to 13 floors florescent detections
with these instruments and right now
because we're you
seeing a Saito 9 + P I we found that
face um having these instruments with
only red and blue lasers activated it's
more than enough but we can always go
back and get the violet laser active if
we ever needed but for now it's working
perfect it gives us great results with
these two lasers and we haven't have any
problems with it so this is just a top
view
um and you can see where the lasers are
located there like color coded and then
you can see to your right the picture of
the front and right where the arrow is
this is where the plate loader goes and
this instrument also gives you a benefit
that if you didn't purchase this
instrument with a plate loader at the
beginning you can always upgrade it
which gives you a lot of flexibility
depending on the high demand of samples
that you need to run so just such a few
tips for success that helped me a lot
during the investigation and looking
into different sample data that we
obtained at the beginning we figured
that having the optimal dilutions sample
it was really critical sometimes if we
had multiple dilutions let's say for
example 10 to the 8 or 10 to the 9th
which is the dilution that we use for
most of these products when we do
traditional plating we realized that we
were not picking out those events in the
flow cytometer
therefore the sample was too diluted and
even though we stain the property and we
follow the procedure we figured that it
was in the optimal dilution if for this
analysis and after different trials we
found 10 to the 4th in 10 to the 5th
work the best
for these type of products so we learned
that and we also learned that trash hole
and gain settings were super super
important because these cells are super
small and at the beginning we had hard
time figuring out where or what was the
best threshold for for these type of
cells and also to not confuse the cell
population with any other noise found or
detected by the instrument so we really
look into trash hole settings and
different um different levels and until
we figured out that what was the best
and I'm gonna show you later on
comparison between two different
settings so you will understand better
what I'm trying to explain to you
another thing is that these
fluorochromes are like sensitive and
it's very important that you protect
those little vials that contain the dyes
protected from the light me personally I
don't like to leave them out in the room
temperature too long so try to prep your
samples in a timely manner and stain
them and incubate them and then put your
dice away and also protect your samples
from light you have to make sure you
protect your samples from any
contaminants because this instrument is
super super sensitive and it's gonna
pick up anything that you load in that
sample tube so basically the instrument
will do whatever you tell the instrument
to do and therefore having a great a
septic techniques really really helped
and takes you a long way then also we
have to ensure the flow rates calibrated
for this instrument we need a
calibration for the tool and also a
calibration for the plate loader just to
make sure that we were having accurate
results and we were not missing
any settings when we on first purchase
this instrument so they experiment that
we designed was for a different species
but the ones that I'm going to talk more
about it's within the lactose and be
film and just because um lactobacillus
was our first easy to start with
lactobacillus is very robust so it's
very easy on specie to to play to stain
for flow cytometry i'm compared to the
film species and the main brain Tegrity
was assessed using site o9 which stains
everything in your sample so anything
that has DNA site o9 it's going to bind
to it either if it's viable or not
viable and then I say counterstain we
use propidium iodide or P I like we know
them and what this does is is going to
bind into any dead cells or any damaged
cells and it allows us to have a
differential towns for viability and
non-viability these are the settings
that we used in the I find the gain
settings set 2004 for scattering side
scatter provided me great results and
the resolution and also the threshold
for the lactobacillus I found best set
on manual and also 50000 for for scatter
and 10000 for this size scatter and also
these settings were set to logarithmic
because it's a better representation of
the world data that we collected and it
definitely shows you a better
presentation of the histograms and
so of the two populations of dead and
live cells so this is the first sample
and this is a control sample that we
loaded and this one is lacto fermented
for mentum and this is on stain and this
is what we saw first and you can see the
you know lactose into the to the left
and also in panel B we have LG G which
is lactobacillus rhamnosus LG G is very
very popular within the products that we
process so it's very very utilized in
many products and then here you see the
difference when we stain a sample we
have on the first panel of the bacterial
population detected on the previous
slides that I just show you and the
histogram in the middle shows you the
beautiful peaks representations for
present 18 ium of the life in dead cells
and these these counts were at the
beginning this is just eliminate data
when we started running the samples but
we definitely were able to find the two
populations and also obtain this nice
graph with a histogram and that allows
or confirmed for us to see the that this
was the bacterial population we were
looking for this is just the another
example lactobacillus rhamnosus these
these in particular I find very easy to
work with with a room gnosis we do the
same procedure staining using Saito 9
and P I and the threshold and gain
settings are exactly the same as I show
you at the beginning and the first final
you can see the bacterial population and
the second one shows you they hate
and the third panel shows you the dead
cells versus life and we were looking
into expected count of three hundred and
fifty billion per gram and we got four
hundred and twenty three and is not a
surprise because when you look into the
plating you won't get as many cells as
we got into the with this flow cytometry
method and this is because in the
plating you're not able to see the
dormant cells and the dormant cells are
able to grow they're not able to show
the colonies but they are not dead that
means that they are metabolically active
and the flow cytometer is able to give
us those cell counts which we cannot get
with a plate and this is one of the of
our favorite things when we get these
these numbers because it shows more
accuracy comparing to on the traditional
method this is a lactobacillus
acidophilus and you can see the little
difference between the previous one in
this one still a lactobacillus but um
it's a little cleaner and the data even
percent as much noise as the other ones
and this is something expected because
depending on the raw material sample
that we are prepping
there is a cryogenic or cryoprotectant
covering these cells and this is just
part of the freeze dry method but um
these cells go through before we get
them into our lab or into our company in
powder form and therefore some of them
might have a gripe protectant that is
thicker layer done others and therefore
can be a little more challenging
for sample preparation or cell staining
process and some of those samples are
going to present cleaner data than
others but because of all the controls
that we ran at the beginning we have
confirmed which are our bacterial
population and we also each sample that
you are seeing here we also played it
which we have the data to support our
experiment and confirmed that we were on
the right track
so for example in this one we have 15
billion program and we were expecting 13
billion program usually in a play count
we will obtain something around 13
billions sometimes we will get a little
over but not as much and so this this
results were grade and were in an
agreement with the play results that we
got this is a comparison between two
different settings and this is why I
said it's so important to understand and
to know what is the optimum settings for
your trash hole and for your gain
settings when it comes to obtain a good
data for these samples and this is a
great example showing the fit along them
and to the left your seen a trash hole
set for 50 in ten thousand four for
scattering site scanner respectively and
you can see how you have these two
populations separated and you can get
them easily compared to the one to the
right where we have a setting of 5000
for for scattering size scatter
respectively and it's a little more
challenging and you can see the
difference in the graph so definitely it
makes a big big difference and it's
super super important that we have the
right settings
or each of these symbols that we deal
with and some of the challenges that I
found um included the sample prep like I
mentioned therefore I had to optimize
the sample breath some of the samples
when I found that the cry protector was
too too thick I had to put the sample in
water mass and this is one example with
a deferral on them I had to make the
dilution and then I had to put it in the
water bath set at 45 degrees for 15 to
20 minutes and then I went ahead and
completed my dilution if I need it
and then stain a sample after several
trials I figured that doing these
treatment for the sample prep provided
me better results than just going
straight out and make the dilutions and
stain the samples because um first of
all sometimes a presented too much
particulates other than the cells and
also require a lot of fixation with
formaldehyde um the data is not shown
here but those were the things of trials
that were performed in the lab to get to
this point and have to were able to
provide these cleaner data or the
separation of two populations this is a
clear example of the settings again so
this one is for lactobacillus rhamnosus
on the left side you see in the
bacterial population when the settings
were set at 50-thousand for for scatter
and 10,000 for side scatter versus 5,000
for scatter and side scatter you can see
the amount of noise outside the gate in
East also was another part of
our studies and seeing how the settings
when they are properly onset can make a
big difference and can also provide a
cleaner data in more accurate numbers in
conclusion after doing several several
trials we figured that we would do
comparative studies in because we want
to make sure that we've really got
accurate data in fact the method of flow
cytometry was really going to increase
our quality control systems we had to do
a lot of platings and this was a big
study for us where we had to play each
simple that we analyzed and a flow
cytometer and we had to compare and
count in and put all a whole report
together and what we found was that
these flow cytometry approach is really
applicable and it's reliable and he
provided what we were looking for and we
we are really satisfied with the results
even though this is all preliminary data
it's it's great advancement in
traditional microbiology and we also
confirm that we are in the right track
because the results that we gather with
a flow cytometer were in agreement with
the plating count and not only that a
workflow improve B time we are able with
this new method to release products in a
timely manner we don't have to wait for
3 days to release them though the raw
materials for our production crew start
to making disciplines and it makes a big
difference because in our company we do
process or test using the traditional
method
2,500 symbols per year and that is a lie
and having 10 to 20 samples per day and
play them and have to sit down and count
these colonies I mean sometimes you
don't have time for that right and these
men that are flow cytometry it's pretty
sweet it's it's very straightforward and
it's so easy to use things from any
super-modern and we are really happy
with it
so the improvement on the timing and and
the the workflow definitely is a plus
and definitely this would be something
that we forward will replace the
traditional method and we will continue
on investigating other type of species
and other type of raw materials for
probiotic supplement manufacturing right
now we are analyzing 20 different
species within the lactobacillus and
bifida so it's a lot of data that we are
looking into but it's promising a lot
and this definitely would be a big big
innovation to the manufacturing of
probiotics in large scale and this would
definitely move traditional microbiology
to the next level so if you have any
questions feel free to let us know and I
also have provided my information at the
end and feel free to contact me with any
questions that you have or any other
things that I might not cover in these
slides that you are interested on
knowing and I'll be more than happy to
answer those questions thank you very
much for your time it's being a pleasure
and I hope this was very informational
educational for everybody
Thank You Darlene for your presentation
a quick reminder for our audience on how
questions simply type them into the
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
Darlene will answer as many questions as
time permits and first question for you
is how reliable is the flow cytometry
technique in comparison to the
traditional plate count method and its
main advantage is it's very reliable
because of all the data that we have
collected using the traditional method
which is our platform that we have been
using for years and years and we have
confirmed and verified over and over the
results that we obtain compared to the
plate in and also with a flow cytometer
and it has been in good agreement which
tells us that that it is too reliable
and that it is a great approach to use
and definitely a technique that we can
trust and that we can rely on great
thank you very much for that one the
next question is what controls were used
during this experiment thank you for
your question for any controls we use on
stain samples and unstained symbols for
each different probiotic cell type and
for each different type of samples
either was raw material or toolable form
we use none stain and we also did a
fixation of samples using formaldehyde
to confirm that we were seeing or
detecting the bacterial populations that
we were looking for okay that is great
looks like we may have one time for one
more question today and that will be was
compensation needed for samples staying
with site o9 and TI not at all because
the spillover of these samples it's very
minimal and therefore there was no need
to
set up for compensation between the two
lasers we've seen these two
fluorochromes so it wasn't necessary
which was of great advantage because um
the data collected using Saito 9 and P I
was straightforward well that is great I
would like to once again thank Darlene
tonto for her presentation do you have
any final comments for us today
um everybody can reach out to me with
questions dawn we covered today in this
section and also any other questions
that we didn't cover here I will be more
than happy to answer it's a lot of data
a lot of information to share and
sometimes even if we want to cover
everything we don't have time but I'll
be more than happy to answer more
questions referring to the experiment or
any other questions related to the
instrument okay very well well thank you
again and I'd like to thank the audience
for joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we
didn't answer today will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
we would like to thank our sponsor
Beckman Coulter life sciences for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through august 2018 lab routes will
alert you via email and it's available
for replay and we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time goodbye